Katrina: 这是谁啊
Katrina: Who is this?
Shure: 啊看我笑的多灿烂啊
Shure: Ah, look how brightly I'm smiling.
Shure: 啊我又暗淡了
Shure: Ah, now I'm dim again.
Shure: 老板知道为什么我暗淡了吗
Shure: Boss, do you know why I'm dim again?
Jack: 因为没给钱是吧
Jack: Because you didn't get paid, right?
Shure: 因为我想涨工资
Shure: Because I want a raise.
Jack: 啊
Jack: Ah.
Shure: 可以了可以了可以了
Shure: Okay, okay, okay.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Jake:准时
Jake: On time.
Shure: 懂懂
Shure: Got it.
Shure: 这叫什么
Shure: What's this called?
Shure: 音乐脱口秀
Shure: Music stand-up show.
Shure: 懂了吧
Shure: Got it?
Alice:你这状态持续多久了
Alice: How long have you been in this state?
Jack: 这是有有病
Jack: This is, this is sick.
Jack: 有病得治
Jack: You need treatment.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey.
Katrina: 你弹的够悲伤的
Katrina: You're playing quite sadly.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Nicous: 妈的 跟着修硕这节奏
Nicous: Damn it, following Shure's rhythm.
Shure: 有一种
Shure: There's a feeling...
Tasha:哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Shure: 怎么我的诗朗诵不好吗
Shure: What, my poetry reading wasn't good?
Katrina: 特别好都想哭了
Katrina: It was so good, it almost made me cry.
Jack: 太好了
Jack: It was great.
男嘉宾:关了
Male Guest: Turn it off.
Shure: 我都不知道难忘今宵的歌词是啥
Shure: I don't even know the lyrics to "Unforgettable Tonight".
Jake:就就这个
Jake: It's just like this.
Shure: 难忘今宵
Shure: Unforgettable Tonight.
Shure: 我们大家一起大合唱
Shure: Let's all sing it together.
刘婷:这是你们的固定节目吗
Liuting: Is this your regular program?
Jack: 我们来点年头小点的吧
Jack: Let's pick a newer song.
Alice:哈哈是吧
Alice: Haha, right?
Shure: 年头小点的歌
Shure: A newer song.
Shure: 怎么你你哈哈哈
Shure: What, you, hahaha.
Jack: 哎这个可以可以
Jack: Hey, this one is good.
Alice:我俩坐那吧
Alice: Let's sit there.
Jake:难忘哈哈哈
Jake: Unforgettable, hahaha.
Alice:你把凳子搬过来呗
Alice: Move the chair over here.
Katrina: 他改精神攻击了
Katrina: He's switched to mental attacks now.
Jack: 你就会这一句是吧
Jack: You only know this one line, right?
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes.
Jake:不行了不行
Jake: Can't do it anymore.
Jake:你还要加工资
Jake: You still want a raise.
Shure: 什么
Shure: What?
Jake:你还要加工资
Jake: You still want a raise.
Shure: 对啊
Shure: Yeah.
Jack: 这应该 扣精神损失费是吧
Jack: This should be a follow-up insult, right?
Shure: 大家有有什么想听的歌吗
Shure: Does anyone have a song they want to hear?
Shure: XBZ都会弹
Shure: XBZ can play anything.
Nicous: 我会库吗
Nicous: Can I do it?
Nicous: 哎呀这终于恢复正常了
Nicous: Finally, things are back to normal.
Nicous: 来来来找个什么歌唱什么
Nicous: Come on, let's find a song to sing.
Shure: 唱什么
Shure: What to sing?
Shure: 你刚才说什么
Shure: What did you just say?
Shure: 不会
Shure: No way.
Jack: 看起来可以唱
Jack: Looks like you can sing it.
女嘉宾:真的很会唱啊
Female Guest: Really sings well.
Jack: 能唱就唱
Jack: If you can sing, then sing.
Shure: 给大家表演一个
Shure: I'll perform for everyone.
Shure: 每次都会在酒后给大家表演的
Shure: I always perform for everyone after drinking.
Shure: 叫什么来着哈哈
Shure: What's it called again, haha
Shure: 对
Shure: Right
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on
Alice:本人不伤心
Alice: I'm not upset
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on
Alice:试这个点心
Alice: Try this snack
Shure: 就四个和弦
Shure: Just four chords
Shure: 你往低了点弹不就得了吗
Shure: Can't you play it a bit lower?
Shure: 哎呀我都能
Shure: Oh, I can do it
Shure: 弹到哪了
Shure: Where did I play?
Shure: 就1645四个和弦
Shure: It's just 1645, four chords
Shure: 我我我我我怎么怎么起的啊
Shure: How did I start again?
Shure: 哎怎么怎么卧槽
Shure: Oh, how... what the heck
Jack: 我又寡言掉了你懂个叫我行不
Jack: I'm being quiet again, can you call me?
Shure: 我我我我最啊我最爱
Shure: I, I, I, I, I love it the most
Shure: 卧哎卧槽
Shure: Oh, what the heck
Shure: 哈哈哈等一下
Shure: Hahaha, wait a minute
Alice:气急败坏
Alice: Frustrated
Shure: 啊啊啊找到了
Shure: Ah, found it
Shure: 谢谢大家谢谢大家
Shure: Thank you everyone, thank you
Alice:你喝酒不喝
Alice: Do you drink?
Alice:我给你拿杯子
Alice: I'll get you a glass
Shure: 好了我们的egoKTV
Shure: Okay, our egoKTV
Nicous: 下一首
Nicous: Next song
Jack: 下一首
Jake: 下一首
Jake: Next song
Shure: 别下一首了哈哈哈
Shure: No more next song, haha
Shure: 一会老底都揭没了怎么办
Shure: What if we reveal all secrets?
Jack: 下一首
Jack: Next song
Shure: 哎大家大家
Shure: Hey everyone
Alice:露西
Alice: Lucia
Shure: 还会唱什么
Shure: What else can you sing?
Alice:露西
Alice: Lucia
Alice:哦在这
Lucia:嗯
Alice: Come closer
Shure: 还听过什么
Shure: What else have you heard?
Shure: 就是能大家一起调动氛围一起唱的
Shure: Something that can get everyone to sing along
Lucia:想你了
Lucia: Miss you
Shure: 想你了
Shure: Miss you
Lucia:哦不不不
Lucia: Oh no, no, no
Shure: 想谁了哈哈哈
Shure: Miss who, haha
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahaha
Lucia:人家想我了哈哈
Lucia: You missed me, haha.
Shure: 哎呀想想想想
Shure: Oh yeah, I missed you a lot.
Shure: 别普通朋友了哈哈
Shure: Don't just be an ordinary friend, haha.
Shure: 老老在这唱这多晦气是吧哈哈
Shure: Singing this song here is so unlucky, right? Haha.
Shure: 什么东西
Shure: What's this?
Shure: 你这什么风格
Shure: What's your style here?
Jack: 你今天弹这个
Jack: You're playing this today?
Jack: 应该有很多什么情歌之类的
Jack: Should be a lot of love songs or something like that.
Jack: 就流沙嘛
Jack: Like quicksand.
Jack: 爱情好像流沙
Jack: Love is like quicksand.
Jack: 不复挣扎嘛
Jack: No more struggling.
Lucia:出现
Lucia: Appear.
Shure: 我这就
Shure: I'll just...
Lucia:你今天晚上住这边吗
Lucia: Are you staying here tonight?
Shure: 主要已经脱离了那个唱苦情歌的阶段
Shure: Mainly, I've moved on from singing sad love songs.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
男嘉宾:有了对像了是吧
Male Guest: You've got someone now, right?
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes.
Katrina: 那你唱那个
Katrina: Then sing that one.
Jack: 那那那来点甜甜的吧
Jack: Yeah, sing something sweet.
Katrina: 你唱那个
Katrina: Sing that one.
Katrina: 恋爱ING吧反正你也是恋爱ING
Katrina: Sing "In Love", you're in love anyway.
Shure: 恋爱ING的词是什么来着
Shure: What are the lyrics to "In Love"?
Shure: 那那有点唱不上去
Shure: That one is a bit hard to sing.
男嘉宾:情非得已
Male Guest: "Cannot Help It".
Alice:咋啦
Alice: What's up?
刘婷:快跟人亲热亲热快点
Liu Ting: Go get close to them quickly.
Katrina: 情非得已也行
Katrina: "Cannot Help It" is fine too.
男嘉宾:有何不可
Male Guest: Why not?
Katrina: 唱素颜吧
Katrina: Sing "Barefaced".
Alice:我鞋呢
Alice: Where are my shoes?
Katrina: 对着你女朋友唱素颜
Katrina: Sing "Barefaced" to your girlfriend.
Jake:哎唱素颜了
Jake: Hey, sing "Barefaced".
Alice:我这人不爱穿鞋有什么毛病
Alice: I don't like wearing shoes, is that a problem?
Katrina: 你女朋友给你唱那个
Katrina: Your girlfriend can sing that.
Katrina: 她唱女生不
Katrina: Does she sing female parts?
男嘉宾:来点那什么小小那个
Male Guest: How about a bit of that one?
Alice:我又不脚臭
Alice: My feet don't smell.
Shure: 来嘛
Shure: Come on.
Katrina: 素颜嘛
Katrina: Let's go natural.
Shure: 唱一个素颜来了
Shure: Sing "Natural Look" then.
Shure: 素颜来了
Shure: "Natural Look" it is.
Katrina: 来嘛
Katrina: Come on.
Shure的女友:等会我再喝口
Shure's GF: Wait, let me have a drink first.
Alice:我去给他拿杯子
Alice: I'll get him a glass.
Shure: 行
Shure: Alright.
叉叉:素颜 素颜
Jack: Natural look, natural look.
Shure: 来给我给我也整一杯
Shure: Come on, get me a glass too.
Alice:哎哟
Alice: Oh dear.
Shure的女友:还有杯子吗
Shure's GF: Any more glasses?
Alice:来我给你洗一个
Alice: Here, I'll wash one for you.
Alice:哎没了我靠
Alice: Oh no, we're out.
刘婷:用碗也行
Liu Ting: A bowl works too.
Alice:好那我就碗了啊
Alice: Okay, I'll use a bowl then.
Shure的女友:这没杯子了吗
Shure's GF: No more glasses left?
Alice:这没了
Alice: Yeah, we're out.
Shure: 你能可以只弹左手
Shure: Can you play with just your left hand?
Shure: 刘帅要不你替我弹
Shure: Choiszt, how about you play for me?
Choiszt: 我没听过你弹这个
Choiszt: I've never heard you play this before.
Shure: 你弹弹就行
Shure: Just go ahead and play it.
Katrina: 你没听过这歌
Katrina: You haven't heard this song?
Shure: 哎OK OK
Shure: Hey, OK, OK.
男嘉宾:喂 喂
Male Guest: Hello, hello.
Alice:给
Alice: Here you go.
Alice:擦过了哈哈哈
Alice: It's been wiped, hahaha.
Alice:不用这么客气
Alice: No need to be so polite.
Shure: 怎么还整俩碗呢
Shure: Why do we have two bowls?
Shure: 结拜了是吗
Shure: Are we swearing an oath?
Katrina: 哎这是啥意思
Katrina: Hey, what's that supposed to mean?
Alice:让我过去
Alice: Let me pass.
Shure: 我要那 就要 还没
Shure: I want that, just that, not yet...
Alice:你要吗露西哦你不能喝哦
Alice: Do you want it, Lucia? Oh, you can't drink.
Lucia:我不喝
Lucia: I don't drink.
Alice:刘婷你喝不喝
Alice: Liu Ting, do you want to drink?
Alice:你别喝了
Alice: You better not drink.
Alice:小孩不让喝酒
Alice: Kids aren't allowed to drink.
Lucia:这不是饮料这是水
Lucia: This isn't a drink, it's water.
Shure: 可以可以哇哈哈哈
Shure: Alright, alright, hahaha.
男嘉宾:用碗
Shure: 你说啥
Shure: What did you say?
Alice:没杯子
Alice: No cups.
Lucia:微醺
Lucia: Tipsy.
Shure: 纯饮一碗是吧
Shure: Just drink a bowl straight, right?
Katrina: 农夫山泉微醺水
Katrina: Nongfu Spring Tipsy Water.
Jack: 可以可以
Jack: Alright, alright.
Shure: 随便随便
Shure: Whatever, whatever.
Katrina: 行你两个小时确实有点
Katrina: Okay, two hours is indeed a bit much.
Alice:你喝吗 哦你不喝
Alice: Are you drinking? Oh, you're not drinking.
Alice:我今晚怎么回事
Alice: What's going on with me tonight?
Lucia:一顿乱回
Lucia: Such a mess.
Jack: 可以啊 厉害呀
Jack: That's fine, impressive.
Jake:手挺狠啊
Jake: Quite bold, huh?
Jack: 要喝好啊
Jack: Drink up if you want.
Alice:紫棠你要吗
Alice: Violet, do you want some?
Katrina: 拜拜拜拜
Katrina: Bye, bye, bye.
Alice:我下去给你找个杯子啥的
Alice: I'll go down and find a cup or something.
Shure: 哎呀不好
Shure: Oh no, that's not good.
Alice:你不要吗
Alice: You don't want any?
Katrina: 那我把他送到门口吧走吧
Katrina: Then I'll walk him to the door, let's go.
Alice:你要吗你要吗
Alice: Do you want some? Do you want some?
Alice:我给你找个容器
Alice: I'll find you a container.
Jack: 啥也不可以
Jack: Nothing is allowed.
Alice:我给你拿个
Alice: I'll get you one.
Katrina: 你知咋出去不虽然我自已也不在
Katrina: Do you know how to get out? Even though I'm not here myself.
Alice:拿个容器
Alice: Get a container.
Alice:我来都来了
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina: 迷宫啊
Katrina: A maze, huh?
Katrina: 这一片我第一次出来时候也绕半天
Katrina: The first time I came out here, I also got lost for quite a while.
Katrina: 这咋了 哈哈哈哈 咋了
Katrina: What's going on? Hahaha, what's going on?
Katrina: 要不要再带一个小蛋糕走
Katrina: Want to take another small cake?
Alice:杯子呢
Alice: Where's the cup?
Alice:没杯子了？
Alice:哎，这呢，这有
Alice:这有一次性的
Alice: There's a disposable one here.
Alice:还有小蛋糕呢
Alice: And there's a small cake too.
Alice:刘婷拿个巧克力
Alice: Liu Ting, grab some chocolate.
Alice:你的朋友要走了吗
Alice: Is your friend leaving?
Katrina: 对她回去两个小时
Katrina: Yeah, she's heading back, two hours.
Alice:对你看
Alice: Yeah, see?
Alice:那得小心点
Alice: Be careful then.
Alice:我来洗吧
Alice: I'll wash it.
Alice:但是这要一次性的
Alice: But this has to be disposable.
Alice:要玻璃杯
Alice: We need glass cups.
Katrina: 今天是世界地球日
Katrina: Today is Earth Day.
Alice:对不起对对对对不起
Alice: Sorry, sorry, I'm really sorry.
Alice:我有罪
Alice: My bad.
Alice:我来洗吧
Alice: I'll wash it.
Alice:嗯好
Alice: Okay.
Alice:我拿纸
Alice: I'll get the paper.
Alice:纸呢
Alice: Where's the paper?
Alice:没有纸吗
Alice: No paper?
Alice:哦在这
Alice: Oh, here it is.
Alice:这个擦得更干一点
Alice: This one wipes drier.
Alice:你这是挂耳染吗
Alice: Is that an ear dye?
女嘉宾:这边
Female Guest: Over here.
Shure的女友:啊对之前是
Shure's GF: Ah yes, it was before.
Shure的女友:然后现在长出来了
Shure's GF: Now it's grown out.
Alice:你是I人吗
Alice: Are you an I person?
Shure的女友:哦是的哦
Shure's GF: Oh yes.
Alice:哦
Alice: Oh.
Shure: 一般一般一般
Shure: It's so-so.
女嘉宾:够了够了够了
Female Guest: It's enough, it's enough.
女嘉宾:一张其实够了好的
Female Guest: One sheet is actually enough, okay.
Shure: 这个这个
Shure: This one, this one.
Alice:走吧
Alice: Let's go.
Shure: 我开始学老板反向画饼哈哈哈
Shure: I'm starting to learn how to reverse-promise like the boss, haha.
Shure: 来吧你给我倒回去吧
Shure: Come on, pour it back for me.
Shure: 放这吧放这吧
Shure: Put it here, put it here.
Shure: 我倒回去
Shure: I'll pour it back.
Alice:给你拿巧克力
Alice: Here, have some chocolate.
Lucia:谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Jake:就朝着弱智吧那路去了
Jake: Heading down the path of an idiot.
Alice:恩将仇报是吧
Alice: Repaying kindness with vengeance, huh?
Shure: 我们我们
Shure: We, we...
Shure: 这个是人类
Shure: This is human...
Shure: 其实是一些正常的活动
Shure: Actually just some normal activities.
Jake:哎正常活动
Jake: Yeah, normal activities.
Jake:都很正常
Jake: Everything is normal.
Shure: 不不不造作
Shure: Not pretentious.
Shure: 不
Shure: Not...
Jake:就 就你不喝酒就唱不上去
Jake: You just can't sing without drinking.
Jake:这很的
Jake: It's true.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Jake:对 这个就
Jake: Yeah, this...
Shure: AI根本想不到这点对吧
Shure: AI would never think of that, right?
Shure: 能啊
Shure: It can.
Jack: 你错过了
Jack: You missed it.
Jake:再来一次
Jake: Let's do it again.
Jack: 精彩发言
Jack: Great speech.
男嘉宾:你说高不高呢
Male Guest: Do you think it's high?
Jack: 这样
Jack: Like this.
Jack: 这你 你先说
Jack: You, you go first.
Jack: 你说高不高吧
Jack: Do you think it's high or not?
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 哎我靠
Shure: Oh my god.
Shure: 来吧女嘉宾
Shure: Come on, lady guest.
Alice:吃提拉米苏不吃
Alice: Want some tiramisu?
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on.
Alice:我给你切一个吧
Alice: I'll cut a piece for you.
男嘉宾:刚刚喝酒干嘛呢
Male Guest: What were you doing while drinking?
Shure: 对啊
Shure: Yeah.
Alice:拿着啊
Alice: Take it.
男嘉宾:你已经忘了喝酒干嘛了
Male Guest: You already forgot why you were drinking.
Jake:呵呵看来喝挺多
Jake: Haha, looks like you drank a lot.
男嘉宾:已经倒半天了
Male Guest: It's been pouring for a while.
Alice:这有水
Alice: There's water here.
男嘉宾:嗯
Male Guest: Hmm.
Alice:行
Alice: Got it.
Alice:别玩抽象
Alice: Don't be abstract.
Shure: 词写上了
Shure: The lyrics are up.
Jake:有 有词有词
Jake: Yes, there are lyrics.
Shure: 呃你稍微放大一点
Shure: Uh, can you enlarge it a bit?
Jake:呃
Jake: Uh.
Shure: 刘帅好OK
Shure: Choiszt, okay.
Jake:我 我来给你播
Jake: I'll play it for you.
Shure: 然后你来翻谱对OK
Shure: 这回能看清了吧
Shure: Can you see it clearly now?
Shure: 我
Shure: I...
男嘉宾:倒酒
Male Guest: Pour the wine.
Shure: 来吧来吧拿 过来
Shure: Come on, come on, take it.
Alice:我给你拿个勺子类的东西
Alice: I'll get you something like a spoon.
Shure: 来吧准备
Shure: Come on, get ready.
Alice:我不是这个
Shure: 可以了
Shure: It's done.
Alice:你修修图啊稍等我
Alice: Can you touch up the picture? Wait for me.
Shure:  一段就可以了
Shure: One section is enough.
Jack: 你有没有拍下去呢
Jack: Did you take the shot?
男嘉宾:刚刚发生了什么
Male Guest: What just happened?
Jake:啊没看见
Jake: Ah, didn't see it.
Alice:什么什么什么
Alice: What, what, what?
Alice:波啦
Alice: Oh no.
Jake:OK OK没关系这边有个机会
Jake: OK, OK, no worries, there's another chance here.
Alice:哎呀
Alice: Ah, geez.
Katrina: 我今天晚上受不了了
Katrina: I can't take it anymore tonight.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha
Katrina: 啊真难受
Katrina: Ah, it's really uncomfortable.
Katrina: 点一首唯一
Katrina: Play "The Only One".
Alice:在来一块
Alice: Come on, another piece.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on.
Nicous: 小黄 唱吧
Nicous: Nicous, sing it.
Katrina: E了
Katrina: I'm done.
Shure: 您来唱
Shure: You sing.
Katrina: 真E了
Katrina: Really, I'm done.
男嘉宾:咱心里
Male Guest: In our hearts.
男嘉宾:也是难以
Male Guest: It's also difficult.
Tasha:也是男女
Tasha: It's also about men and women.
Shure: 我不会
Shure: I don't know it.
Shure的女友:那首我真不会
Shure's GF: I really don't know that song.
Shure的女友:这首还唱过
Shure's GF: I've sung this one before.
Shure的女友:那首真不会
Shure's GF: I really don't know that one.
男嘉宾:OK
Male Guest: OK.
男嘉宾:告五人的是不是王力宏的
Male Guest: Is it by "告五人" or Leehom Wang?
Shure: 对 告5人的
Shure: Yes, it's by "告五人".
Shure: 告五人的
Shure: It's by "告五人".
Shure: 告5人的
Shure: 告五人你弹的是王力宏的
Shure: The one you're playing is by Leehom Wang.
Shure: 你谈的是王力宏的啊
男嘉宾:这是告五人的吗
Male Guest: Is this by "告五人"?
Jack: 啊告五人
Jack: Ah, it's by "告五人".
Jack: 这这这跟那个有什么区别吗
Jack: What's the difference between this one and that one?
Nicous: 是两个两个
Nicous: They are two different ones.
Shure: 完全不一样的歌
Shure: Completely different song.
Nicous: 完全不一样
Nicous: Totally different.
Shure: 两种不一样
Shure: Two different kinds.
Jack: 哦
Jack: Oh.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on.
Katrina: 我真的能唱吗
Katrina: Can I really sing?
Shure: 你可以的
Shure: You can do it.
Katrina: 来
Katrina: Let's go.
Shure: 你不行少和弦就行
Shure: If you can't, just play fewer chords.
Katrina: 你帮我合着点
Katrina: Can you help me a bit?
Shure: 我还帮你合着点
Shure: I'll help you a bit.
Katrina: 就大家帮我合着点
Katrina: Everyone help me out a bit.
Katrina: 我一个人唱我的声音我会觉得很尴尬
Katrina: I would feel really awkward singing alone.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Katrina: 我看从哪开始
Katrina: Let's see where to start.
Katrina: 我靠挺好我不知道从哪进
Katrina: I have no idea when to start.
Alice:吃提拉米苏吗我给你切一块
Alice: Want some tiramisu? I'll cut you a piece.
Katrina: 你能提示一下吗
Katrina: Can you give me a cue?
Lucia:我下午吃了
Lucia: I had some this afternoon.
Alice:他说挺好吃的
Alice: He said it was really good.
Lucia:对我也觉得挺好吃的
Lucia: Yeah, I think it’s really good too.
Lucia:是吧
Lucia: Right?
Katrina: 我也觉得
Katrina: I think so too.
Alice:吃提拉米苏吗我给你切一块
Alice: Want some tiramisu? I'll cut you a piece.
Shure: 哎我直接弹了得了
Shure: Hey, I'll just play it.
Shure: 来吧来吧
Shure: Come on, come on.
Shure的女友:我吃过了
Shure's GF: I’ve had some.
Alice:你要吗
Alice: Do you want some?
Lucia:我们俩一起吃的
Lucia: We had it together.
Shure: 你这怎么D调你知道吗
Shure: Do you know how to play this in D?
Alice:你要吗给你切一下
Alice: Do you want some? I'll cut you a piece.
男嘉宾:我从来不用这些
Male Guest: I never use these.
Alice:我得给你找个容器
Alice: I’ll find you a container.
Shure: 我草
Shure: Damn.
Shure: 你给我移个调我就可以可以
Shure: Change the key for me and I can play it.
Alice:给你用这个吧
Alice: Use this.
Katrina: 这是在干什么呢
Katrina: What are you doing?
Alice:你在乱叫吗
Alice: You're just making noise.
Alice:我杀了你
Alice: Mom, I’ll kill you.
Shure: 等一下啊
Shure: Hold on.
Shure: 我稍等我稍微移个调就可以
Shure: Wait a bit, I'll just change the key a little.
Shure: 你怎么移调啊
Shure: How are you changing the key?
男嘉宾:这歌你没听过吗
Male Guest: Haven't you heard this song before?
Shure: 哎
Shure: Eh?
Katrina: 没听过吗
Katrina: Haven't heard it?
Nicous: 哦这这这这这个
Nicous: Oh this, this, this...
Jake:这两天来少了
Jake: You've been coming less these days.
男嘉宾:不会每天都唱吧
Male Guest: You don't sing every day, do you?
Katrina: 每天都唱这首歌一到晚上
Katrina: We sing this song every night.
Jake:每天都唱
Jake: Every day.
Shure: 要不这个我帮你弹
Shure: How about I play it for you?
男嘉宾:啊
Male Guest: Huh?
Jack: 哦
Jack: Oh.
Shure: 你这调对吗你想想
Shure: Is this the right key? Think about it.
Alice:露西亚让我过一下下
Alice: Lucia, let me pass for a moment.
Lucia:啊好的
Lucia: Ah, sure.
Alice:哎我看有点
Alice: Eh, let me see...
Lucia:这个呃是不是还要在
Lucia: Is this, uh, still necessary?
Alice:噢噢谢谢
Alice: Oh, oh, thanks.
Lucia:没事
Lucia: No problem.
Lucia:嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Jake:谢彬竹没搞定
Jake: Xie Binzhu didn't get it done.
Shure: 你就全程在这翻手机
Shure: You've been on your phone the whole time.
Shure: 你在你在后面有什么用
Shure: What are you doing back there?
Shure: 四级
Shure: Level four.
Shure: 然后你往上移半个调不就得了吗
Shure: Then just move it up half a key, isn't that enough?
Shure: 笨死了可
Shure: So dumb, seriously.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Eh.
Katrina: 从头吗
Katrina: From the beginning?
Jack: 从头吧
Jack: From the start.
Shure: OK能不能找到了哥
Shure: OK, can you find it this time?
Shure: 这次
Shure: This time...
Shure: 这这次
Shure: This, this time...
Shure: 那我就给你声开大点了啊
Shure: Then I'll turn up the volume for you.
Alice:要哪个
Alice: Which one?
Shure: 真没有问题了
Shure: No more problems now.
Shure: 哈哈哈哎
Shure: Hahaha, eh.
Nicous: 准备
Nicous: Ready?
Jake:你又行了了是吧
Jake: You're good to go now, right?
Shure: 他又行了
Shure: He's good to go.
Alice:行
Alice: Okay
Shure: 能不能找到他哥
Shure: Can we find his brother?
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm
Shure: 那刚才不是完事了吗
Shure: Wasn't it finished just now?
Alice:能给我发个消息吗找不着你了
Alice: Can you send me a message? I can't find you.
Shure: 好终于对上了
Shure: Finally matched up.
Alice:太卡了
Alice: It's too laggy.
Shure: 你在你在后面有什么用
Shure: What's the point of you being in the back?
Katrina: 来
Katrina: Come on.
Alice:搜不到
Alice: Can't search.
Jake:你真的懂
Jake: You really get it.
Jake:呀
Jake: Ah.
Katrina: OK哦
Katrina: OK.
Katrina: 换下一首
Katrina: Next song.
Shure: 还有要表演的同学
Shure: Any other students performing?
男嘉宾:靖康
Male Guest: Jingkang.
Shure: 靖康你会唱什么
Shure: Jingkang, what can you sing?
Katrina: 唱一首
Katrina: Sing a song.
Shure: 这老板得唱一首吧
Shure: The boss should sing a song, right?
Shure: 唱什么老板啊
Shure: What can you sing, boss?
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah?
男嘉宾:你会唱什么
Male Guest: What can you sing?
Katrina: 爱拼才会赢
Katrina: "Love to Fight Will Win"
Jake:行来
Jake: Alright, come on.
Shure: 真的吗
Shure: Really?
Shure: 老板真会唱吗
Shure: Can the boss really sing?
Jake:不会
Jake: No.
Shure: 老板会会
Shure: The boss can, can.
Shure: 会唱点什么吗
Shure: Can you sing something?
Alice:yes OK
Alice: Yes, OK.
女嘉宾:are you OK
Female Guest: Are you OK?
Jake:are you OK
Jake: Are you OK?
Katrina: 他的手机铃声
Jake:are you OK这个倒是可以
Jake: "Are you OK" is doable.
Shure: 哎呦
Shure: Oh no.
Lucia:婧康的手机铃声
Lucia: Jingkang's ringtone.
Jake:are you OK
Jake: Are you OK?
Alice:are you OK
Alice:hello
Alice: Hello.
Shure: 那我
Shure: So I...
Shure: 这怎么办呢
Shure: What should we do?
Shure: 这这大家以后你看
Shure: This, everyone, look
Shure: 这就是一个情商小课堂
Shure: This is an emotional intelligence mini-class
男嘉宾:富士山下
Male Guest: Under Mount Fuji
男嘉宾:哦
Male Guest: Oh
Jack: 可以可以
Jack: Okay, okay
Alice:我现在就去山东进修
Alice: I'm going to Shandong for training now
Shure: 可以
Alice:呃山东
Alice: Uh, Shandong
Alice:呃哈哈哈哈
Alice: Uh, hahaha
Alice:情商小课堂
Alice: Emotional intelligence mini-class
Shure: are you OK哈喽
Shure: Are you okay, hello
Lucia:我靠
Lucia: Oh my god
Shure: 老板来
Shure: Boss, come here
Shure: 我觉得这样也可以
Shure: I think this works too
Shure: 咱们也不尴尬
Shure: We're not awkward either
Jake:用不着用不着
Jake: No need, no need
Jake:用不着
Jake: No need
Jake:用不着用不着
Jake: No need, no need
Shure: 要成功哈哈哈
Shure: To succeed, hahaha
Jake:先打
Jake: First hit
Lucia:不是谁是老板啊
Lucia: Who's the boss?
Shure: 老板老板
Shure: Boss, boss
Jake:用不着
Jake: No need
Jake:用不着用不着
Jake: No need, no need
Jake:呃算了
Jake: Uh, forget it
Jake:哈哈挺会
Jake: Haha, quite good
Katrina: 这弹啥了
Katrina: What was that?
Shure: 他把老板的歌词给弹了
Shure: He played the boss's lyrics
Shure: 这种一般都怎么处理呢
Shure: How do you usually handle this?
Alice:送去山东
Alice: Send to Shandong
Jack: 不趁着人多的时候说话知道不
Jack: Don't talk when there are many people, you know?
Shure: 我感觉这样
Shure: I feel like
Shure: 明天他左脚就可能踏进公司了吧
Shure: Tomorrow his left foot might step into the company
Shure: 呃
Shure: Uh
Katrina: 那个唱富士山下
Katrina: That song, Under Mount Fuji
Shure: 所以所以XBZ
Shure: So, so, XBZ
Jack: 可以
Jack: Okay
Shure: 你你在这里的
Shure: You, you are here
Katrina: 起一个什么作用呢
Katrina: What role does it play?
Shure: 气氛组
Shure: It's to set the mood.
Katrina: 起一个logo作用哈哈哈
Katrina: It acts like a logo, haha.
Shure: logo怎么这牌子
Shure: A logo? What's this brand?
Shure: 打钱了是吗
Shure: Did they pay?
Katrina: 唱点经典的
Katrina: Sing some classics.
Katrina: 大家都会的
Katrina: Ones everyone knows.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Sure.
Katrina: 周杰伦陈奕迅
Katrina: Jay Chou, Eason Chan.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Jack: 可不可以又弹又跳一条龙
Jack: Can you play and dance all at once?
男嘉宾:这有点难
Male Guest: That's a bit tough.
Shure: 你好
Shure: Hello.
Shure: 没事看看你
Shure: It's okay, just checking on you.
Shure: 没事 不用不用
Shure: It's fine, no need.
Katrina: 这个词有点难看到
Katrina: This word is a bit hard to see.
Shure: 对你这上不了桌回家的时候
Shure: Right, you can't put this on the table at home.
Shure: 现在先坐小孩的时候历练2年
Shure: For now, let the kid train for 2 years.
Shure: 哼 什么好的好的
Shure: Hm? Alright, alright.
Alice:好吗
Alice: Is that okay?
Alice:好的
Alice: Okay.
Katrina: 好吧好的
Katrina: Alright, sure.
Alice:好的
Alice: Okay.
Alice:大兵打人装修吗
Alice: Is the soldier hitting people or renovating?
男嘉宾:来一个来一个来一个
Male Guest: Do one, do one, do one.
Alice:再来一块吗还吃吗
Alice: Want another piece? Still hungry?
Jack: 给你拿麦  我给你拿麦
Jack: I'll hold the mic for you.
Shure: 这太浓了
Shure: This is too strong.
Jack: 我负责给你拿麦
Jack: I'll hold the mic for you.
Shure: 就跟我
Shure: Just with me.
Shure: 要不给我就稍微倒一点
Shure: Or just pour a little for me.
Alice:有但是太杂了这根本就没有一个
Alice: There is, but it's too messy, there's no one.
Shure: 陈奕迅啊这是
Shure: Eason Chan, right?
Shure: 兑一起然后再分一半
Shure: Mix it together, then split it in half.
Shure: 我给他录一个
Shure: I'll record one for him.
Lucia:哇好厉害
Lucia: Wow, amazing.
Shure: 啊他那天说的
Shure: Ah, that's what he said that day.
Shure: 哇谢彬竹
Shure: Wow, Xie Binzhu.
Shure: 终于默契了一次
Shure: Finally, we have a moment of synergy.
Shure: 我懂了问题出在我身上
Shure: I get it, the problem is with me.
Shure: 不是不是你身上
Shure: No, no, it's not with you.
Shure: 懂了懂了
Shure: Got it, got it.
Shure: 跟跟跟那个帅师傅比较
Shure: Comparing with Master Choiszt,
Shure: 比较投缘是吧
Shure: You seem to get along better, right?
Nicous: 下一个
Nicous: Next one.
Shure: 下一个
Shure: Next one.
Jake:哎别你别你别
Jake: Hey, no, no, no.
Shure: 靠 好
Shure: Damn, okay.
Nicous: 你来一个
Nicous: You give it a try.
Jake:对你来一个
Jake: Yeah, you try it.
男嘉宾:不用啦
Male Guest: No need.
Shure: 我们有全民K歌
Shure: We've got 全民K歌 (Karaoke app).
Katrina: 实在不行普通朋友
Katrina: If it doesn't work, just friends.
男嘉宾:普通朋友
Male Guest: Just friends.
Katrina: 大家一起唱就没事
Katrina: Everyone sings together, no problem.
Katrina: 来来来
Katrina: Come on, come on.
Katrina: RNB是非常适合这种氛围的
Katrina: R&B is perfect for this kind of atmosphere.
Katrina: 没关系挺可爱
Katrina: It's okay, it's pretty cute.
Katrina: 没事
Katrina: It's fine.
Shure的女友:都很喜欢
Shure's GF: Everyone likes it.
Jack: 给给给找个词呗
Jack: Give us some lyrics.
男嘉宾:哦
Male Guest: Oh.
Shure: 发完了记得删
Shure: Remember to delete it after sending.
Shure: 别被你女朋友发现了
Shure: Don't let your girlfriend find out.
Shure: 你不是孤优从立
Shure: You aren't孤优从立 (independent).
Jake:把手扳了
Jake: Twist your hand.
Shure: 很好
Shure: Very good.
Shure: 加入了最后一句
Shure: Added the last line.
Shure: 具有个人特色的rap部分
Shure: With a unique personal rap part.
Shure: 这谢彬竹每次最后一下叮一下就是哎
Shure: This谢彬竹 (Xie Binzhu) always adds a finishing touch at the end.
Shure: 非点睛一下
Shure: Gotta put a final touch.
Shure: 就是除了内我基本没听清哈哈哈
Shure: Apart from that, I basically didn’t hear clearly, haha.
Nicous: 两条进不去啊没歌词
Nicous: Two lines can’t fit, no lyrics.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Shure: 好该谁了
Shure: Okay, whose turn?
Shure: 到谁了
Shure: Whose turn is it?
Katrina: 会弹的不就你们两个吗
Katrina: Aren’t you two the only ones who can play?
男嘉宾:对呀
Male Guest: Yeah.
Katrina: 点歌呗
Katrina: Request a song.
Shure: 主要我我唱的
Shure: Mainly, I sang it.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Katrina: 你点个呗
Katrina: Can you pick one?
Shure: 好别摘不下来
Shure: Alright, don't take it off.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Uh-huh.
Shure: 这个这个呢
Shure: This one, this one.
男嘉宾:好摘
Male Guest: Easy to take off.
Shure: 那如果摘不下来呢
Shure: What if it doesn't come off?
男嘉宾:好摘
Male Guest: Easy to take off.
Shure: 哦只要不丢就行
Shure: Oh, as long as we don't lose it.
Shure: 但是手指手指可以去是吧
Shure: But fingers, fingers can go, right?
Nicous: 这什么
Nicous: What's this?
Shure: 淘汰
Shure: Eliminated.
Katrina: 前面怎么唱来着
Katrina: How did the front part go?
Shure: 这也不能顶
Shure: This can't stand either.
Shure: 那我那我先摘一个
Shure: Then I'll, I'll take one off first.
Shure: 摘不下来的时候
Shure: When it doesn't come off.
其他人:哎呀别别别别别
Shure: 到时候跟我妈妈哭
Shure: Then I'll cry to my mom.
Shure: 妈妈你看
Shure: Mom, look.
Shure: 他把我这个戒指抢走还摘不下来
Shure: He took my ring and couldn't take it off.
Shure: 妈给他剁了哈
Shure: Mom, chop it off for him.
其他人：:我知道不能丢
Shure: 好好好
Shure: Alright, alright, alright.
其他人:这个丢了我真哭给你看
Shure: 我知道我知道
Shure: I know, I know.
Katrina: 受不了了
Katrina: I can't take this.
Katrina: 这对小情侣
Katrina: This couple.
Katrina: 我怎么看不清词啊
Katrina: Why can't I see the words clearly?
Shure: 几天怎么这么爱我
Shure: How can you love me so much these days?
Shure: 多爽啊
Shure: It's so nice.
Shure: 还每天能拿300块
Shure: And we can get 300 bucks every day.
Shure的女友:没有其实每个周末跟你出去玩的话
Sister Shure: Actually, if we go out every weekend,
Katrina: 直接拍情侣写真了
Katrina: We'll just take couple photos directly.
Shure的女友:会是在正常生活中
Sister Shure: It will be in our normal life.
Jake:草 这他妈怎么起来
Jake: Damn, how did this happen?
Shure的女友:然后出现一点很失去的情况
Sister Shure: And then there will be some moments of loss.
Shure的女友:但是特别好
Sister Shure: But it's really good.
Shure的女友:只要我正常生活也没有什么很好的
Sister Shure: As long as I live normally, there's nothing too great.
Alice:是的
Alice: Yes
Katrina: 哎  哎哟什么时候我也有男朋友
Katrina: Sigh, when will I have a boyfriend too?
Shure: 无妨
Shure: It doesn't matter.
Katrina: 拍一个哈哈哈
Katrina: Take a picture, haha.
Lucia:前面那些歌我都没听过
Lucia: I haven't heard any of those songs before.
Alice:你应该不怎么听中文歌吧
Alice: You probably don't listen to Chinese songs much, right?
Lucia:我听得比较少
Lucia: I listen to them quite rarely.
Lucia:因为我有几个很喜欢的歌手
Lucia: Because I have a few favorite singers.
Shure的女友:就你知道他们在那找吗
Shure's GF: Do you know where they find them?
Lucia:然后听他们听的比较多
Lucia: So I listen to their songs a lot.
其他人:我上回跟Darry和顾老师
Lucia:所以留下的听别的歌的时间就很少
Lucia: So there's very little time left to listen to other songs.
其他人:两个人去唱歌玩
Shure的女友:那天你也知道
Shure's GF: You know that day too.
Jake:走道没了
Jake: The path is gone.
Shure的女友:然后就是我说陈奕迅OK这首
Shure's GF: And then I said, "Eason Chan, okay this one."
Shure的女友:然后他们跟我说
Shure's GF: And then they told me...
Alice:有点困了
Alice: I'm a bit sleepy.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Shure的女友:就是我找那种
Shure's GF: I was looking for...
Lucia:发现无法融入歌单
Lucia: I found it hard to fit into the playlist.
Shure的女友:我感觉大家都会唱的歌
Shure's GF: I felt like everyone could sing the songs.
Lucia:变得I了起来
Lucia: Became kind of isolated.
Shure的女友:他说OK这一首我好像知道
Shure's GF: They said, "Okay, this one I might know."
Alice:没事你本来就I 无所谓
Alice: It's okay, you were already isolated, doesn't matter.
Shure的女友:但是我不会唱
Shure's GF: But I can't sing it.
Katrina: 周杰伦还有什么歌
Katrina: What other songs does Jay Chou have?
Shure的女友:然后你在说什么
Shure's GF: And then you said...
Shure的女友:那你为什么要找粤语歌
Shure's GF: Why were you looking for Cantonese songs?
Shure的女友:你找粤语歌
Shure's GF: You were looking for Cantonese songs.
Shure的女友:你不找伊森的歌
Shure's GF: You weren't looking for Eason's songs.
Shure的女友:什么东西
Shure's GF: What is this?
Shure的女友:最后唱的什么
Shure's GF: What was the last song we sang?
Shure的女友:就是反正大家会唱粤语歌
Shure's GF: Anyway, everyone could sing Cantonese songs.
Shure的女友:但是唱的什么我也不知道
Shure's GF: But what were we singing, I don't know.
Shure的女友:忘记了忘记了
Shure's GF: I forgot, I forgot.
Shure: 东北人有自己的一套粤语体系
Shure: Northeastern people have their own set of Cantonese songs.
Shure: 知道吗哈哈哈哈
Shure: You know that? Hahaha.
Shure的女友:不是啊戴瑞家山西的啊
Shure's GF: No, Darry's family is from Shanxi.
Alice:他没带走
Alice: He didn't take it.
Lucia:好可爱
女嘉宾:戴瑞是山西人
Female guest: Dai Rui is from Shanxi.
Katrina: 这我也听过
Katrina: I've heard that too.
Katrina: 这不是高中的时候
Katrina: Wasn't this from high school?
Shure的女友:我忘了山西哪里了
Shure's GF: I forgot where in Shanxi.
Shure的女友:但反正是山西人
Shure's GF: But he's definitely from Shanxi.
Lucia:不要拆散我们的小狗cp
Lucia: Don't break up our little dog couple.
Katrina: 听的诗班淡淡的
Katrina: Listening to the choir softly.
Lucia:刚好
Lucia: Just right.
Alice:那狗子CP
Alice: That dog couple.
Lucia:狗子CP嗯
Lucia: Yeah, the dog couple.
Lucia:好可爱真可爱这花花也做得好好
Lucia: So cute, really cute, and the flowers are done so well.
Alice:你可以把这个头拆走
Alice: You can take this head off.
Katrina: 哈哈这首好适合吉他弹
Katrina: Haha, this song is perfect for playing on guitar.
Lucia:我去找一个你拆
Lucia: I'll go find one, you take it off.
Alice:谢谢
Alice: Thanks.
Lucia:啊 谢谢
Lucia: Ah, thanks.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Mm-hmm.
Alice:没事你喜欢的话你拿走也行
Alice: No problem, if you like it, you can take it.
Shure的女友:啊就是拍卖的开辟
Shure's GF: Ah, so the auction has started.
Shure的女友:已经不属于他的买家了是吗
Shure's GF: It no longer belongs to the buyer, right?
Jack: 对呀
Jack: Yeah.
Alice:对
Alice: Yeah.
Lucia:对对
Lucia: Yeah, yeah.
Jack: 啊好过分啊
Jack: Ah, that's so unfair.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Alice:困了有点
Alice: I'm a bit sleepy.
Alice:我真的困了
Alice: I'm really sleepy.
Shure: 自已倒啊
Shure: Pour it yourself.
Alice:确实，还很累
Shure的女友:气泡水和朗姆其实还可以
Shure's GF: Sparkling water and rum are actually pretty good together.
Shure: 洗发水应该买的
Shure: You should have bought shampoo.
Shure的女友:但我感觉
Shure's GF: But I feel...
Shure的女友:我感觉它最好
Shure's GF: I feel it's best...
Shure的女友:其实是伏特加是最好的
Shure's GF: Actually, vodka is the best.
Shure的女友:但是不知道为什么你们没买
Shure's GF: But I don't know why you didn't buy it.
Shure: 我有半瓶一直说要带来的
Shure: I had half a bottle that I kept saying I'd bring.
Shure: 一直谁过来的时候都忘了带
Shure: Every time someone comes over, I forget to bring it.
Shure的女友:像罗舒兰这种东西
Shure's GF: Like Rosulan kind of thing...
Shure的女友:我觉得他只适合做少婷
Shure's GF: I think it's only good for making Shouting.
Shure的女友:你买一瓶罗舒兰
Shure's GF: You should buy a bottle of Rosulan.
Shure的女友:我其实不是很不是很理解
Shure's GF: I actually don't really, don't really understand.
Shure的女友:不是很理解就是这种
Shure's GF: I don't really get this kind of...
他虽然那个入口特别好
Shure's GF: Even though the entrance is really good.
Shure的女友:但是他他对我来说只适合做绍兴
Shure's GF: But to me, it's only suitable for Shaoxing.
Shure的女友:前几年真的挺流行
Shure's GF: It was really popular a few years ago.
Shure的女友:真的
Shure's GF: Really.
Shure的女友:但是但是
Shure's GF: But, but...
Shure的女友:在网易云的那个归类里面
Shure's GF: In NetEase Cloud's classification...
Shure的女友:功德被归到了说唱
Shure's GF: "Gongde" was classified as rap.
Shure的女友:i mean the why
Shure's GF: I mean, why?
Shure: 因为他有他有关联的
Shure: Because it's related.
Shure: 比如说像豆芽这种课
Shure: Like "Douya" class.
Shure的女友:可能all right
Shure's GF: Maybe, all right.
Shure: rap是多吧
Shure: Rap is a lot.
Shure: 又开始了
Shure: Here we go again.
Shure的女友:对对对
Shure's GF: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Shure的女友:但他不是他不是
Shure's GF: But it's not, it's not...
Shure的女友:他真的不是
Shure's GF: It's really not.
Shure的女友:你可以把归到任何一个类
Shure's GF: You can classify it as anything.
Shure的女友:就是甚至你把归到华语大流行都行
Shure's GF: You can even classify it as Mandarin pop, but...
Shure的女友:但他真的不是说唱
Shure's GF: It's really not rap.
Shure的女友:其实你可以把我背到口中
Shure's GF: Actually, you can put me in your mouth.
Shure的女友:我也不知道
Shure's GF: I don't know either.
Shure的女友:音乐人的乐园
Shure's GF: Musician's paradise.
Shure: 谁知道
Shure: Who knows.
Alice:拉炼我呢
Lucia:噢
Lucia: Oh.
Alice:我一定看好吗
Alice: I'm definitely looking, okay?
Alice:我一定看啊
Alice: I'm definitely looking.
Alice:结束了吗还是什么
Alice: Is it over or what?
Alice:这是干嘛
Alice: What's going on?
Alice:什么环节
Alice: What segment is this?
Lucia:无法融入歌单
Lucia: Can't fit into the playlist.
Lucia:大部分都没听过
Lucia: Most of them haven't been heard.
Shure: 给你胖了
Shure: Made you fat.
Shure: 你不是怕被踢了
Shure: Weren't you afraid of getting kicked out?
Alice:什么刘婷要唱凤凰传奇
Alice: What, Liu Ting wants to sing Phoenix Legend?
Shure的女友:高了高了高了
Shure's GF: Too high, too high, too high.
Lucia:没有谱子
Lucia: No sheet music.
Lucia:可是伴奏同学依然会弹
Lucia: But the accompanist is still playing.
Jack: 果然这个歌词你不会了
Jack: As expected, you don't know the lyrics.
Alice:后面不会了
Alice: I don't know the later part.
Jack: 找一下词好吗
Jack: Can you find the lyrics?
Shure的女友:啊不这种歌只要记住副歌就行
Shure: Ah, no, for this kind of song, you just need to remember the chorus.
Alice:凤凰传奇上
Alice: It's Phoenix Legend.
刘婷:我其实也不太会唱
Guest: I actually can't sing it well either.
Jake:再找一个再找一个
Jake: Find another one, find another one.
Jack: 除了副歌的词一遍也记不住
Jack: Except for the chorus, I can't remember any of the lyrics.
刘婷:主要是上吧
Guest: Mainly, it's just for fun.
Alice:上吧上吧
Alice: Yeah, let's just go for it.
刘婷:图个氛围
Guest: It's all about the vibe.
刘婷:不是我会
Guest: It's not that I can sing it well.
Shure: 不我们有
Shure: No, we have...
Shure: 我们有全民k歌这个软件的
Shure: We have this karaoke app, you know?
Shure: 你知道吗
Shure: Do you know it?
Jack: 分分钟需要你
Jack: "Need You Every Minute".
男嘉宾:都不太会唱
Guest: No one really knows how to sing it well.
Shure的女友:啊不刚刚他就在啊
Shure: Ah no, he was just here.
Shure的女友:刚刚还跟我说说为什么不能唱那个啊
Shure: He was just telling me why we can't sing that one.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure的女友:就是就是就是
Shure: Just, just, just...
Shure: 我们有有有
Shure: We have, have, have...
Shure: 全民k歌的
Shure: The karaoke app.
Jack: 为什么没有唱吧之类的
Jack: Why don't we have something like "Changba"?
Shure: 来来来我们是有的
Shure: Come on, come on, we do have it.
Shure: 大家
Shure: Everyone...
Jack: 吉他这边就自个看
Jack: Just look at the guitar here.
Jack: 然后我们另外一个手机
Jack: And we have another phone.
Jack: 放在KTV的那个
Jack: Put it in the KTV machine.
男嘉宾:对对对来吧
Guest: Yeah, yeah, go ahead.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Go ahead.
Shure: 我们其实早就为了这个k歌程序的啊
Shure: We actually prepared this karaoke program long ago.
Shure: 什么
Shure: What?
男嘉宾:婧康真的不要高歌一曲
Guest: Jinkang, don't you want to sing a song?
男嘉宾:这可是我们宝贵的数据资源车呀
Guest: This is our precious data resource car.
Alice:今天
Alice: Today...
男嘉宾:468861哦你摄影他就要拍了
Guest: 468861, oh, you're filming, he's about to shoot.
男嘉宾:然后就不会说两个一起的
Guest: So, they won't speak together.
男嘉宾:也有道理啊
Guest: Makes sense.
Tasha:把电脑拿给我呗
Tasha: Hand me the computer, please.
Shure: 唉好
Shure: Alright, sure.
Tasha:还有 对
Tasha: And... yeah.
Alice:我也想我想睡了
Tasha:搞不完了快
Tasha: Hurry up, we can't finish this.
Shure的女友:你可以就是
Shure's GF: You can just...
Alice:卸完
男嘉宾:陈奕迅的粤语歌词
Male Guest: Eason Chan's Cantonese lyrics.
男嘉宾:我的粤语都是来吧
Male Guest: All my Cantonese is from...
Shure: 来吧咱们
Shure: Come on, let's...
Shure: 咱们可以点了
Shure: We can order now.
男嘉宾:海阔天空
Male Guest: "Boundless Oceans, Vast Skies"
Jack: 我来搜一搜
Jack: Let me search for it.
男嘉宾:因为我去KTV就唱了哪些歌
Male Guest: Because when I go to KTV, I sing those songs.
Nicous: 我下班了吧
Nicous: I'm off work now, right?
Shure: 对你可以下班了
Shure: Yeah, you can clock out.
Shure: 操
Shure: Damn.
Shure: 咱开 4块钱
Shure: Let's start, 4 yuan.
Shure: 4块钱杨老板能报一下不到1新币
Shure: 4 yuan, Jake can reimburse, it's less than 1 SGD.
Jake:多少钱
Jake: How much is it?
男嘉宾:4块
Male Guest: 4 yuan.
Shure: 4块
Shure: 4 yuan.
Jake:4块多少新币
Jake: How much in SGD?
Shure: 0.8新币
Shure: 0.8 SGD.
Jake:那有点超预算了
Jake: That's a bit over budget.
Jake:哈哈哈买买买
Jake: Hahaha, buy it, buy it, buy it.
男嘉宾:838080高
Male Guest: 838080 tall.
女嘉宾:已经四五年了
Female Guest: It's already been four or five years.
男嘉宾:我我唱情非得已
Male Guest: I... I sing "Can't Help Falling in Love".
Jack: 他们有那个什么网
Jack: Do they have that net thing?
Jack: 有那个什么情歌网
Jack: Do they have that love song net thing?
Shure的女友:麦给我麦给我
Shure's GF: Give me the mic, give me the mic.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Huh?
Shure: 现在有吗
Shure: Do we have it now?
Shure的女友:有有有
Shure's GF: Yes, yes, yes.
Shure: 有是吧
Shure: We have it, right?
Shure: 有吧
Shure: OK OK
Shure: OK, OK.
Shure: 再再试一下
Shure: Try it again.
Shure: 现在有了OK
Shure: We have it now, OK.
Jack: 哎呀
Jack: Oh my God.
Shure: 稍等稍等
Shure: Hold on, hold on.
Shure: 我把把这个PPT退掉啊
Shure: I'll close this PPT.
Shure: OK OK这回就
Shure: OK, OK, now it's...
Jake:有啥压力比较大
Jake: What's causing the most stress?
Shure: 我是不是应该打打个招呼说叔叔好
Shure: Should I say hello to him, like "Hi, uncle"?
Shure的女友:嫌我不好看
Shure: Thinks I'm not good looking.
Shure: 跟个DJ一样
Shure: Just like a DJ.
Shure: 但是他一个人被逮住了
Shure: But he got caught alone.
Shure的女友:摸鱼看摸鱼
Shure: Watching someone slack off.
Shure: 我这数据不能要了
Shure: I can't use this data anymore.
Jack: 情非得已来
Jack: Come on, can't help it.
Katrina: 来
Katrina: Come on.
Jack: 我切了啊
Jack: I'm cutting it off.
Shure: 啊不不保存
Shure: Ah no, don't save it.
Shure: 所有的都不保存你
Shure: Don't save any of it.
Shure: 大家想让我保存吗
Shure: Do you all want me to save it?
Nicous: 唉 给他们存着
Nicous: Hey, save it for them.
Shure: 第一个就是第一个就是
Shure: The first one is, the first one is...
Shure: 然后点开始唱歌对
Shure: Then click to start singing, right?
Shure: 你稍微离近一点
Shure: Move a bit closer.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes.
Jake:噢
Jake: Oh.
Shure: 为什么这首歌
Shure: Why this song?
Shure: 这首好像伴伴奏有点小
Shure: This accompaniment seems a bit low.
Alice:再录会
Alice:我靠
Alice: Damn.
Alice:我这几天没有说脏话
Alice: I haven't cursed these past few days.
Alice:但你来了之后
Alice: But since you came,
Alice:我发现我需要逼掉的音特别多
Alice: I realized I have to bleep out a lot more words.
刘婷:是我的问题
Liu Ting: It's my fault.
刘婷:脏话不是从你嘴里说出来的吗
Liu Ting: Aren't the curses coming from your mouth?
Alice:脏话憋在心里心就脏了
Alice: If you hold in curses, your heart gets dirty.
Alice:说出来心就亮了
Alice: Saying them out makes your heart brighter.
Shure的女友:发布一些假情报
Shure: Spreading some false information.
男嘉宾:搞点粤语歌哎
Male Guest: Sing some Cantonese songs.
男嘉宾:哎你会唱粤语
Male Guest: Hey, you can sing in Cantonese?
Shure的女友:今天中午跟我讲说你知道吗
Shure: Today at noon, you told me...
Nicous: 来个海阔天空
Nicous: Sing "Boundless Oceans, Vast Skies".
Shure的女友:那个你舍友回家了
Shure: That your roommate went home.
男嘉宾:好好我不知道你是因为会粤语
Male Guest: Okay, I didn't know you could speak Cantonese.
Shure的女友:我说怎么可能
Shure: I said, how is that possible?
男嘉宾:还是你最喜欢陈奕迅
Male Guest: You still like Eason Chan the most.
Shure的女友:我今天中午我吃完饭回回寝室的时候
Shure's GF: Today, when I went back to the dorm after lunch...
男嘉宾:所以你陈奕迅的歌粤语的标准
Male Guest: So your Cantonese is as good as Eason Chan's songs.
Shure的女友:他他他他刚买了两盒水果回来
Shure's GF: He just bought two boxes of fruit.
Nicous: 等我来一个海阔天空我就下班
Nicous: Let me finish "Boundless Oceans, Vast Skies" then I'll clock out.
Shure的女友:他怎么可能回家了
Shure's GF: How could he have gone home?
Nicous: 下班海阔天空嗓子就没了没事
Nicous: Singing "Boundless Oceans, Vast Skies" will ruin my voice, but it's okay.
Shure的女友:我看到他跟他妈妈推出行李箱出去了
Shure's GF: I saw him and his mom pushing a suitcase out.
Shure的女友:我说不可能
Shure's GF: I said, that's impossible.
Shure的女友:然后昨天晚上我回寝室的时候
Shure's GF: And then last night, when I went back to the dorm...
Shure的女友:发现我的舍友在宿舍里面看电影
Shure's GF: I found my roommate watching a movie in the dorm.
Alice:哈
Alice: Huh
女嘉宾:开始
Female Guest: Start.
刘婷:穿黑裙那小美女身材好好
Liu Ting: The girl in the black dress has such a great figure.
Alice:哦哦
Alice: Oh, oh.
Alice:咱也下去吧
Alice:哎小心小心
Alice: Hey, be careful, be careful.
Alice:最近感觉超上火
Alice: Lately, I've been feeling super irritated.
Alice:想洗脸了
Alice: I want to wash my face.
刘婷:去吧
Liu Ting: Go ahead.
Alice:真嘟吗
Alice: Really?
刘婷:老了到点困了有点
Liu Ting: I'm getting old, starting to feel sleepy.
Alice:真的吗
Alice: Really?
刘婷:你不你不你不卸妆吗
Liu Ting: Aren't you going to remove your makeup?
Alice:洗 等我一下
Alice: Wash up, wait a second.
Alice:看还有多少
Alice: Let's see how much is left.
Lucia:都可以吃吧
Lucia: Can we eat all of this?
Jake:哈哈当然不是的干嘛
Jake: Haha, of course not, why?
Lucia:请示一下领导
Lucia: Asking the boss for permission.
Jake:不吃这些东西呢
Jake: If we don't eat these, what should we do with them?
Jake:怎么处理呢
Jake: How should we handle it?
Alice:今天几点下班
Alice: What time do we get off work today?
Jake:好问题我也不知道
Jake: Good question, I don't know either.
Alice:困了
Alice: I'm sleepy.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia:领导都 不知道几点下班
Lucia: Even the boss doesn't know when we get off work.
Alice:领导这个不知道有点
Alice: It's a bit...
Alice:还蛮好的
Alice: It's quite nice.
Jake:那 咱
Jake: So, we...
Jake:咱
Jake: So...
Alice:好的
Alice: Okay
Jake:咱是咱是
Jake: We're, we're...
Jake:算什么点
Jake: What time is it?
Jake:十一 十一  十一十一六 十一十一七
Jake: Eleven, eleven, eleven sixteen, eleven seventeen
Alice:十一十一7
Alice: Eleven seventeen
Jake:十一十一7
Jake: Eleven seventeen
Jake:哈哈 确实 太博学了
Jake: Haha, indeed, so knowledgeable
Jake:这个
Jake: This...
Jake:是是是我错了我错了
Jake: Yes, yes, I was wrong, I was wrong
Jake:这每天十一十一七的玩
Jake: Playing hard every day until eleven seventeen
Jake:高强度玩耍
Jake: High-intensity playing
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Alice:11点结束之后还得网购买东西
Alice: After finishing at eleven, you still have to shop online
Lucia:不要太离谱
Lucia: Don't be so ridiculous
Jake:太高强度了
Jake: Too intense
Alice:算加班
Alice: Consider it overtime
Jake:还加班还加班还加班
Jake: Still overtime, still overtime, still overtime
Lucia:对还要加班
Lucia: Yeah, still have to work overtime
Jake:店还没开
Jake: The shop isn't even open yet
Jake:好嘞好嘞
Jake: Alright, alright
Alice:闯入人家闺房干什么啊
Alice: What are you doing barging into someone's room?
刘婷:你不许进来
Liu Ting: You're not allowed to come in
Jake:只是他不许进来哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Only he's not allowed to come in, hahaha
Alice:倒返天罡了
Alice: That's a bit too much
Alice:倒返天罡了这
男嘉宾:开 香槟那果酒呢
Male Guest: Open, where's the champagne and fruit wine?
Lucia:开始录8%居然就可以了
Lucia: Start recording, 8% is actually enough
Jake:对 5%以上应该是
Jake: Yes, it should be over 5%
Lucia:哎不愧是领导
Lucia: Wow, no wonder you're the boss
Alice:哎这眼镜感觉损耗了
Alice: Oh, these glasses seem to be wearing out
Alice:就是这几天发现充着电还是耗电
Alice: Recently, I've noticed that even when charged, they still drain power
Lucia:对刚开始我觉得差
Lucia: Yeah, at first I thought it was bad
Alice:尊嘟 真
Alice: Really
Alice:真的吗
Alice: Really?
Alice:这个如果用坏了不还要买新的吗
Alice: If this breaks, won't we need to buy new ones?
Lucia:没事这捐给他们了
Lucia: It's okay, we donated it to them
Alice:哦
Alice: Oh
Jake:咱们咱项目要不
Jake: Should we, should we...
Jack: 领导不差钱
Jack: The boss isn't short on money
Jake:主要是捐的
Jake: Mainly donated.
Jake:就主要是这批货只要不用坏就能用
Jake: As long as this batch isn't wasted, it can be used.
Jake:咱下一批就下一批
Jake: For the next batch.
Alice:等于说你想用新的呗
Alice: So you want to use new ones.
Jack: 哦特意搞坏的
Jack: Oh, deliberately damaged.
Alice:这是可以录的吗
Alice: Can this be recorded?
Jack: 已经录下了
Jack: It's already recorded.
Lucia:咦确实就算我们眼镜没开过户也开了
Lucia: Yeah, even if our glasses haven't been opened, they have been.
Alice:就是一直通着电之后还是一个那啥
Alice: Even if the power is always on, it's still the same.
Jake:噢
Jake: Oh.
Lucia:对他还是会断我觉得
Lucia: Yeah, it will still break, I think.
Lucia:前两天没这样
Lucia: It wasn't like this a couple of days ago.
Alice:一边进水一边放水还是放的快
Alice: Water coming in on one side and going out on the other, it's still draining fast.
Lucia:什么小学数学题
Lucia: What kind of elementary math problem is this?
Jack: 没事 漏得快没关系
Jack: It's fine, let it leak fast, no problem.
Alice:小学数学题
Alice: Elementary math problem.
Jake:挺好挺好
Jake: Great, great.
Jake:就把它就是
Jake: Just...
Jake:最大的价值是吧 剥削掉
Jake: Extract the maximum value, right?
Jake:我们剥削眼镜最大的价值
Jake: We exploit the maximum value of the glasses.
Jake:外头还有啥吃的呀
Jake: Is there any food outside?
Jake:嗯外头还有啥吃的
Jake: Hmm, any food outside?
Alice:还有披萨
Alice: There's pizza.
Alice:你饿了吗
Alice: Are you hungry?
Jake:披萨
Jake: Pizza.
Jake:我没饿我就想知道
Jake: I'm not hungry, just curious.
Jake:我就想看看咱们
Jake: Just wanted to check.
Alice:披萨披萨
Alice: Pizza, pizza.
Alice:这啥呀哦
Alice: What's this, oh.
Alice:淄博小饼还有啊
Alice: There's still Zibo pancakes.
Alice:这啥这啥玩意
Alice: What's this, what's this thing?
Alice:这个被挡着了
Alice: This is blocked.
Alice:根本没开
Alice: Not even opened.
Alice:我给你看着 我给你看着
Alice: I'll keep an eye on it for you.
Alice:花甲吧应该
Alice: Should be clams.
Jake:噢
Jake: Oh.
Jake:怕是没人吃
Jake: Afraid no one will eat it.
Alice:估计没看见
Alice: Probably didn't see it.
Alice:其实都是
Alice: Actually, it's all...
Jake:帅
Jake: Cool.
Jake:我觉得就是夜里一辆奔驰就帅
Jake: I think a Benz at night is just cool.
Alice:酷
Alice: Cool.
Lucia:很赛博朋克
Lucia: Very cyberpunk.
Jake:对 就是
Jake: Yeah, exactly.
Jake:穿长裙然后亮了灯就太帅了
Jake: Wearing a long dress with lights on is just too cool.
Lucia:我们这外面要收拾一下么
Lucia: Should we tidy up outside?
Lucia:哎呀感觉其实每次
Lucia: Oh, it feels like every time...
Alice:都剩一点
Alice: There's always a bit left.
Lucia:对就算有剩的收拾了吃剩的吧
Lucia: Yeah, even if there's leftovers, we should pack them up and eat the leftovers.
Lucia:也不够再再点的话又多了
Lucia: It's not enough, and if we order more, it's too much again.
Jake:不要丢掉全都丢掉
Jake: Don't throw it away, throw it all away.
Alice:老板不差钱
Alice: The boss isn't short on money.
Lucia:不会烧吧
Lucia: It won't burn, right?
Jake:还能怎么办嘛
Jake: What else can we do?
Jake:收起来有什么用
Jake: What's the use of keeping it?
Lucia:这是什么呀这是
Lucia: What is this anyway?
Jake:花甲
Jake: Clams.
Alice:这是估计被那个饼挡着了
Alice: It's probably blocked by that pancake.
Lucia:哦
Lucia: Oh.
Alice:没吃
Alice: Didn't eat it.
Jake:被遗忘的花甲
Jake: Forgotten clams.
Lucia:没事反正也不吃
Lucia: It's okay, we don't eat it anyway.
Lucia:这玩意
Lucia: This thing...
Alice:都都扔了吗
Alice: Are we throwing it all away?
Alice:要不放冰箱里
Alice: Or put it in the fridge?
Alice:明天早上万一有人吃呢
Alice: Maybe someone will eat it in the morning.
Jake:那这太万一了
Jake: That's a big maybe.
Alice:昨天的汉堡还在冰箱
Alice: Yesterday's burger is still in the fridge.
Lucia:我也想起来了
Lucia: I remember that.
Lucia:昨天的汉堡还在冰箱里 可贵了那个
Lucia: Yesterday's burger is still in the fridge. It was expensive.
Jake:确实
Jake: True.
Jake:喝点桃汁吧
Jake: Let's have some peach juice.
Alice:你喝吧
Alice: You drink it.
Alice:幸亏我们没有怎么淋雨
Alice: Luckily we didn't get too wet in the rain.
Jake:有
Jake: We did.
Alice:确实有
Alice: We did get wet.
Jake:上周也是这么来的是吧
Jake: Last week was the same, right?
Jake:第 就是你
Jake: The... you know...
Jake:第一天晚上听到有人唱歌
Jake: The first night we heard someone singing.
Lucia:我没听到过
Lucia: I haven't heard of it.
Lucia:但是好像有个同学跟我提到过
Lucia: But it seems like a classmate mentioned it to me.
Lucia:说前一天好像有人啊 唱K
Lucia: They said someone was singing karaoke the day before.
Jake:噢噢 是是
Jake: Oh, oh, yes, yes.
Lucia:我不知道
Lucia: I don't know.
Lucia:我不确定那个同学是不是你
Lucia: I'm not sure if that classmate was you.
Jake:可能是我
Jake: It might have been me.
Lucia:因为大家当时刚认识
Lucia: Because we just met everyone at that time.
Lucia:还有点拘谨和真诚
Lucia: We were a bit reserved and sincere.
Jake:有一点有 还有一点真诚
Jake: A bit reserved, and also sincere.